the metaphor I'm feeling is like you
you're going to a horse race and trumps
your horse for instance and you're like
I that guy he's gonna win I got
everything we need this horse to win but
like they own the arena where the horse
is running they set all the rules in
real time they can have new Runners come
onto the race at any moment they can
actually tell your horse to stop running
and go sit down during the race so how
do you expect that horse to win
well first of all I want to get
something out the way I was out January
6 I was in Washington DC I was there at
the rally now I did not go to the
Capitol so FBI don't come knocking on my
damn door I did not go to the Capitol uh
but I was there and Trump had nothing to
do with people uh uh busting out windows
or whatever was going on at that Capitol
he did not tell people to Riot Trump
would Trump trump is all about peace
he's all about peace and I was there so
so them going after him for for January
6th is just straight up bogus so I just
want to get that get that out the way
because I was there